[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce vendredi 13 novembre
l'actualité du jour c'est l'institut
humaine safe qui vient en aide aux
victimes de violences conjugales et
intrafamiliales qui a lancé un appel aux
dons avec la crise sanitaire son
activité a augmenté de 250%
elle a besoin de moyens pour continuer à
maintenir le lien avec les victimes
à ce sujet nous recevrons l'adjudante
virginie redureau du groupement de
gendarmerie des yvelines
on fera le point sur la situation
complexe pour les victimes avec les
différents confinement dans l'actualité
également la ville de coignières a remis
en place le service coursier pour venir
en aide aux personnes vulnérables
pendant ce deuxième confinement un
dispositif déjà présent au printemps
dernier enfin l'actualité de la semaine
c'était l'élection du nouveau maire de
bois d'arcy les médiathèques disponible
en dry les manifestations au lycée ou
encore un jeu de société sur les
yvelines le résumé en 78 secondes et
l'actualité c'est aussi la conférence de
jean castex conférence de presse
hebdomadaire du gouvernement sur la
crise sanitaire
jeudi à 18 heures comme c'était
pressenti pas de nouvelles restrictions
dans cette conférence de presse pour ce
confinement mais d'ailleurs pas
d'assouplissement non plus au moins
jusqu'au 1er décembre
le premier ministre a tout de même
précisé que l'allègement possible du
confinement ne concernerait pas les bars
restaurants et salles de sport même dans
15 jours cela signifie que ces
établissements vont donc rester fermés
l'autre annonce de ce point hebdomadaire
c'est l'attestation dérogatoire deux
déplacements qui restera nécessaire
après le 1er décembre
[Musique]
mais avant de recevoir notre invité
l'adjudante virginie redureau pour
parler des violences conjugales et
intrafamiliales l'institut vous menez
continuent à venir en aide aux victimes
malgré le confinement les violences
ayant augmenté le nombre de femmes et
d'enfants ayant besoin d'être aussi la
structure a lancé un appel aux dons pour
pouvoir poursuivre sa mission
reportage avec astrid bergère l'institut
human life a lancé un appel aux dons en
ligne basé à saint germain en laye
depuis 2014 la structure vient en aide
au quotidien aux victimes femmes ou
enfants de violences conjugales et
intrafamiliales
avec le retour du confinement la période
est critique pour le moment 2781 euros
ont été collectés
aujourd'hui les moyens qui nous sont
alloués ne sont pas suffisants avec le
travail qui a aujourd'hui nous est
extrêmement écrasant en termes de moyens
nous ne voulons pas réduire le nombre de
consultations même si on les absorbent
mais on est quand même dans une
augmentation du nombre de consultations
très importante
là il faudrait effectivement qu'on
puisse être aidé pour pouvoir perd à
faire perdurer les consultations et puis
toute l'organisation qui s'est mis
autour car il a fallu que les équipes de
vous une feuille s'adapte à la crise
sanitaire
pendant le premier confinement
l'institut a continué son action
virtuellement une continuité nécessaire
car la hausse des violences a été
considérable alors l'augmentation était
nette puisque deux ça représente 250 %
d'augmentation à la même période donc
c'était c'était plus de 300 femmes que
nous avons reçus dans cette période là
quand on dit recevoir 300 femmes ça veut
dire qu'elles vont venir au moins dix
fois entre le psychologue les cons les
consultations psychologues juristes etc
en plus de l'appel aux dons l'institut
va également lancer une campagne de
communication avec des affiches dans les
commissariats et les lieux publics
le 25 novembre journée internationale de
lutte contre les violences bras
flashcode est la victime pourra
effectivement flashée ce qr code pour
déjà savoir qui nous sommes donc ça va
l'orienter vers notre site
elle pourra après se saisir de notre
de notre numéro de téléphone pour nous
appeler nous expliquer la situation est
évidemment on va la prendre très
rapidement en charge selon le degré
d'urgence qu'elle nous aura évoqué avec
ce deuxième confinement l'institut woman
safe continue donc à maintenir le lien
avec un protocole sanitaire renforcée
les rendez vous peuvent avoir lieu par
téléphone ou au sein même des locaux
bonsoir adjudante virginie redureau vous
font partie de la maison confiance et de
protection des familles fcpf je ne me
trompe pas pour la gendarmerie des
yvelines avant de parler de la situation
des violences intrafamiliales donc
département quel est le rôle de cette
structure
alors déjà cette structure est la
première en france à avoir été inaugurée
donc le 13 octobre 2020 pas revoir
madame la ministre déléguée chargée la
citoyenneté 1 marlène schiappa cette
maison de confiance et de protection des
familles a pour mission de prévenir de
protéger d'aidé et d'appuyer les unités
c'est à dire que c'est un point d'entrée
unique pour tous les partenaires du
département
cette unité aussi permet d'appuyer les
unités territoriales gendarmerie quand
elles nous ont besoin pour la prise en
charge des publics les plus vulnérables
que ça soit les victimes de violences
intrafamiliales
les seniors la jeunesse est aussi les
personnes en situation de handicap et
c'est aussi un outil de coordination des
actions de prévention sur la prise en
charge des violences intrafamiliales en
lien avec les associations d'aidé aux
victimes
qu'est ce qu'on entend on va dire un peu
globalement ce par les violences
intrafamiliales alors c'est les
violences intrafamiliales c'est ce qui
se passe dans la sphère familiale donc
ça soit entre conjoints mais c'est aussi
envers les enfants ascendants
descendants et aussi les seniors qui
habitent sous le même toit
finalement nous sommes rentrés ya deux
semaines dans le 2ème confinement les
gens sont donc chez eux une situation
complexe on l'a compris avec le
reportage sur humaine cf qu'on a vu
juste avant quelle est la situation du
coup actuellement avec ce deuxième
confinement dans les yvelines ont
restons très vigilants par rapport à ce
deuxième confinement
en par rapport à ce qu'on a vu aussi au
premier confinement maintenant les
règles sanitaires sont un peu moins
strictes donc les personnes continuent
quand même aller dans la mesure du
possible travailler les enfants
continuent à aller à l'école
on sent qu'il ya encore des tensions
mais c'est vrai qu'on reste vigilant par
rapport à ce phénomène
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore assez
de recul mais on sait que c'est quelque
chose qui est présent et on y fait très
attention mais parce que je le rappelle
il reste encore deux semaines en tout
cas au moins pour ce deuxième
confinement du coup par rapport au
premier confinement quel bilan avez-vous
vous pu en faire et ce que vous avez vu
une augmentation de ces violences au
sein du foyer
alors oui on a vu une augmentation comme
au plan national où il est estimé à peu
près 30% d'augmentation de ces faits de
violence les yvelines
également on en fait partie on a vu un
phénomène qui n'était peut-être pas
forcément visible là auparavant c'est
ces conflits en fait contre couple qui
n'avait au départ enfin qu'on ne
connaissait peut-être pas de la
gendarmerie
mais le fait de la promiscuité de ces
conjoints d'entre eux ne pas aller
travailler que les enfants restent à la
maison
on a vu une augmentation des
interventions pour des violences surtout
verbales des altercations qui auparavant
n'avaient pas eu d'effet et bien
évidemment sur les personnes qui
souffraient déjà de violence au sein du
foyer
elles ont été exacerbées bien évidemment
est-ce que je joue ça à mener des
poursuites ses interventions que vous
avez fait pendant le premier confinement
oui tout à fait on a on a gardé
cette protection des victimes dont qui
s'est engagé des poursuites au plan
judiciaire bien évidemment avez vous mis
en place des moyens supplémentaires du
coup pour ce deuxième confinement suite
à l'augmentation dès violences pendant
le premier alors on poursuit nos actions
de moyens de communication innovant
puisqu'il faut aller au plus près de ses
victimes alors qu'on ne peut pas rentrer
physiquement en contact avec elle donc
on met des messages de prévention donc
sur le premier confinement les avait mis
sur les sachets de pharmacie avec des
numéros forts comme le 39 19 ou le 119
enfance en danger sur les tickets de
caisse aussi avec l'enseigné intermarché
qui nous avaient suivi dans ce projet là
et aujourd'hui encore on essaye de
trouver des moyens de communication
toujours plus efficaces et innovants
pour atteindre ces personnages dans
leurs foyers y at il des choses que vous
allez mettre en place prochainement
supplémentaire du coût pour pour lutter
contre ces violences donc là on est en
train de réfléchir russo des moyens de
communication peut-être sur des messages
à la radio et éventuellement pour
pouvoir donner les numéros utiles auprès
de ces personnes est encore plus
communiquer sur tout ça on l'a bien
compris qu'elle conseille aujourd'hui si
une femme victime de violences regarde
notre notre émission quels conseils
pouvez vous lui donnez aujourd'hui alors
déjà le premier conseil c'est sortir du
silence bien évidemment en parler aller
vers les forces de l'ordre police ou
gendarmerie ont poussé les portes d'un
commissariat ou d'une brigade de
gendarmerie
il faut pas aussi oublier les autres
moyens qui sont le 39 19 le numéro
d'appel national
le 114 par sms si on est dans
l'impossibilité de parler il y à aussi
la plateforme des violences sexuelles et
sexistes la brigade numérique et le site
arrêtons les violences coin gouv.fr bien
évidemment et le 119 pour l'enfance en
danger faut pas oublier les enfants bien
évidemment et avec toutes ces
plateformes que mis en place tous ses
moyens de dénoncer des violences
est ce que la parole se libère depuis
quelques mois quelques années selon vous
on sent quand même qui a une libération
de la parole qui se fait on aimerait
qu'elle soit toujours plus grande
mais on le sent week elle est présente
et que les victimes dénoncent de plus en
plus lui les faits de violence sur
lequel subissent et bien merci beaucoup
à djeddah en de virginie redureau
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce seul est au
frais
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également la ville de
coignières réinstaure pendant le
confinement le service coursier pour
venir en aide aux personnes vulnérables
disponible du lundi au vendredi ce
service avait déjà été mis en place
pendant le premier confinement c'est la
guette son go a suivi une course pour tv
78 c'est à la résidence les moissonneurs
logements pour personnes âgées qu'eux se
sont rendus ce mardi 10 novembre dans la
matinée le responsable du service
coursier ainsi que deux agents pour
chercher la liste des courses d'une
habitante salat pain fromage des
aliments de première nécessité pour
cette dame atteint d'une pathologie
j'ai plus de 65 ans j'ai 66 j'en ris je
souffre d'une pathologie chronique donc
aujourd'hui fragile
j'ai fait partie de la population
fragile écosystème de courtier et ils
formidable pour moi le terme de
confinement une fois la liste donnée les
coursiers parts au supermarché du coin
avec le bon de commande qui permet
d'avancer les frais ce dispositif avait
été un succès lors du confinement
avec plus de 15 demandes par jour on
descend à 6,7 à la personne qu'ils
appellent par jour d'eau alors d'avoir
avec le temps pour penser peut-être que
ça va peut-être monte en puissance dans
des dans les jours qui viennent ces
services est disponible du lundi au
vendredi sur rendez-vous de 8h30 à 12h15
et de 13h30 à 17h30
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à solliciter ses besoins
c'est une manière d'être solidaire de
participer à ce moment qui est très très
compliqué pour tout le monde et on sait
bien que ces personnes sont très
vulnérables
il ya aussi musulman quelque part donc
nous aussi ça permet de faire de créer
ce lien avec ces personnes qui sont à
l'extérieur
ce dispositif de coursiers maintenu
jusqu'au 1er décembre et pourrait être
prolongé si le confinement est également
l'actualité de la semaine c'est bixente
mais rien senti ban ki nou là résume en
78 secondes
jean-philippe luce a officiellement pris
ses fonctions en tant que maire de bois
d'arcy
il succède à philippe benassaya élu
récemment député des yvelines
l'ancien premier maire-adjoint a déclaré
souhaiter poursuivre les projets déjà
mises en place par son prédécesseur
la ville de plaisir à renforcer son
service maintien à domicile depuis
l'annnonce une deuxième confinement se
sont tus repas sont distribués chaque
jour à des personnes fragiles afin
d'éviter qu'elle ne se déplacent dans
les zones à risque ce service
d'assistance est mise en place par la
mairie pendant toute la durée du
confinement
c'est un soulagement pour les
médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et leurs
adhérents
depuis le samedi 7 novembre service de
drive permet de venir emprunter jusqu'à
cinq documents à la fois les créneaux
sont adaptés et les emprunts sont placés
trois jours en quarantaine avant d'être
prêté à nouveau face à l'incompréhension
autour du nouveau protocole sanitaire
dans les collèges et lycées de nombreux
enseignants et parents d'élèves
expriment leur mécontentement ils
étaient une quarantaine ce mardi devant
la sous préfecture de mantes la jolie
une délégation a d'ailleurs été reçue
par le préfet les auto écoles sont
fermées depuis l'annnonce du second
confinement les élèves ne peuvent plus
prendre d'heures de conduite pourtant
les examens au centre de trappes et
rambouillet sont bel et bien maintenu
les taux de réussite devrait cependant
pas être pris en compte pour les autres
écoles
enfin jeux de société aux couleurs des
yvelines est désormais disponible
le jeu cyr sino le chasseur de trésors
mais enseigne 36 communes pour vivre une
aventure sur plateau à travers le
département
développé par la société familiale créée
à comme games le but est de retrouver
les pièces d'or en s'aidant d'un 10 sur
les cartes des différentes villes ce
vendredi ce sont aussi les cinq ans de
l'attentât meurtrier du 13 novembre 2015
à paris et à saint denis
de nombreuses cérémonies en petit comité
ont eu lieu au stade de france
au bataclan mais aussi aux terrasses qui
avait été prise pour cible dans les 10e
et 11e arrondissement de paris ce jour
là ce sont 130 personnes qui ont perdu
la vie et trois cent cinquante autres
ont été blessées parmi eux cinq
yvelinois claire anne fabrice grigori et
pierre-yves sur son compte twitter le
département des yvelines leur a rendu
hommage ce vendredi matin avec cette
mention
nous ne les oublierons pas pour terminer
cette édition ce samedi 14 novembre
c'est la journée mondiale du diabète
environ 4 5 millions de français sont
diabétiques
le diabète de type 1 ne représentent
environ 10% des cas il n'est pas
forcément très connus maladies auto
immunes
elle se caractérise par une absence
totale de production d'insuline pour
remédier à cela deux jeunes mamans ont
créé trois pièces de théâtre sur cette
maladie qui touche leur enfant est né
reportage de seuil agathe son goût elles
se sont rencontrés sur les bancs du
cours florent puis se sont perdus de vue
elle ne pensait pas que leurs vies
étaient sensiblement les mêmes rebecca
stella et avait la guillou sont deux
jeunes mères qui ont leurs enfants aînés
diabétiques et elle avait donc deux ans
2 environ et puis à la crèche m'avait
appelé en me disant didon votre fille ça
va pas fort un objet de lui donner un
truc à manger à 10 heures sinon elle est
ko elle a tout le temps soit fait
beaucoup pipi vous devriez vérifier le
diabète quand même allé faire une prise
de sang
bon je vais faire une prise de sang mais
bon en fait je n'arrivais jamais à ce
qu'elles soient agents puisqu'elle
continue à manger la nuit elle avait
besoin de boire beaucoup quand ils m'ont
dit elle est diabétique comme avait là
je me suis dit ah ben ça va juste pas
manger de bons becs et et puis après ils
m'ont dit non c'est plus compliqué que
ça on va tout vous expliquer il faut que
vous compreniez il ya beaucoup de
facteurs à prendre en compte ce que vous
sachiez faire les calculs et de ce choc
que ces deux mamans ont vécu l son nom
servi pour écrire une première pièce de
théâtre appelé les îles désertes
salvatrice pour ces deux maires
américains au moins c'était popeck plein
la poche à leurs écrits ont fait un
massacre
on a pu représenter enfin en faire un
grand corps une fois un spectacle ce
qu'est notre métier et en plus on a pu
jouer ce spectacle qui raconte entre
histoire devant des gens dont c'est
l'histoire et après échangé avec un mois
et je pense qu enfin je parle comme pour
rebecca si j'ai grandi avec la première
pièce parle d'une petite fille léa qui a
9 ans et qui apprend qu'elle est
diabétique
en fait les a tués diabétiques tu sais
ce que c'est que le diabète
non pas du tout je vais mourir non tu ne
vas pas mourir
on fait pas un documentaire sur ce que
c'est que de vivre avec un diabète de
type 1 on s'intéresse au point de vue de
l'enfant
et puis de l'entourage et ça on a
vraiment voulu décliner dans chacune de
nos pièces et celle qui a entre autre
inspiré ses spectacles c'est yael 11 ans
la fille de rêver car des fois il y en a
qui me caractérise comme diabétique est
il pas un diabétique c'est pas tout ce
qui me définit diabétiques
on sait jamais la danse je suis
passionné de sport c'est j'adore
dessiner enfin c'est que des trucs comme
ça j'ai pas que ça en moi maintenant je
suis un professionnel pour expliquer
cette maladie mais avant ça m'énervait
et à chaque fois ma mère venait
expliquer et grâce à ce spectacle ça a
évité de venir en bout comme ça donc
c'est cool et cette première pièce de
théâtre a donné lieu à une deuxième les
éclipses
on retrouve les à adolescentes c'est bon
j'ai aimé mon insuline
le dernier volet de la trilogie drapeau
blanc était terminée juste avant le
confinement
l'oea a 18 ans et entre dans l'âge
adulte ce nouveau volet sera donc à
découvrir prochainement puisque
confinement oblige il n'a pas pu encore
être montrées au public
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi nous retrouverons
l'information dans le 7-8 journal lundi
à 18 heures présenté par grégory canale
et jusqu'ici je vous souhaite un très
bon week-end et une très bonne soirée
[Musique]